new findings today from a congressional  investigation  show fisher-price failed to ensure its  rock and play was  safe and ignored warnings it was  dangerous  pediatricians say babies must sleep on a  flat surface  on their backs but the rock and play  sleeper put  infants at a 30 degree angle now the  report finds when the product was  launched back in 2009  there was no independent research or  even internal company research  showing it was safe for babies to sleep  at an angle  something pediatric injury expert dr ben  hoffman finds disturbing  the fact that that there was no due  diligence done  in talking to experts to even  understanding what safe sleep was and  how  the incline sleeper product operated  completely  counter to what we know safe sleep to be  so the rock n play was on the market for  about 10 years it was recalled  the consumer product safety commission  says it is linked now to more than 30  infant deaths some very troubling  findings today